the doctor Erica you've expressed your
disappointment at Barack Obama's speech
to the UN General Assembly on Monday yes
I did because President Obama has all
other leaders that give speeches in the
UN General Assembly yesterday were
united and fight against Isis rightly so
we're with them Isis must be defeated
but I know that ideas cannot be killed
with bullets how can the prisoner states
glitch defeat Isis and to bring
democracy and stability to the region
while ignoring their Israeli occupation
of Palestine while ignoring the
continuation of Israeli settlement
activities and Israeli attacks and
aggression against the holiest of holy
for Muslims which is the Luxor most
methods is there are some reports that
John Kerry asked you to sort of hold off
for a few months they're very busy with
implementing the Iran deal that they
might take another look at the peace
process after six months or so is that
the case no that's not true secretary
Kerry said that President Obama and him
are committed to the two-state solution
are committed to peace and that they
will they will never abandon trying to
make peace between Palestinians and
Israelis based in the two-state solution
that is the truth but when the president
says pledged to continue fighting
against Dash and autocracy and
dictatorship and to bring democracy and
peace and stability in the region and
then decides not to mention a word about
Palestine about the two-state solution
about peace and ignoring the Israeli
dictation settlement activities in 2009
President Obama gave a speech to the
Muslims in Cairo he asked the Israelis
to sub settlement activities ever since
that time Netanyahu increased settlement
activities in the West Bank and East
Jerusalem by twenty percent so what
message is the President Obama sending
the region now there's been speculation
that Mahmoud Abbas in his speech on
Wednesday will make a big announcement
he himself I think he's used the word
bombshell what can we expect I think we
should wait to hear this [ __ ] is going
to be tomorrow at 1pm after his speech
the Palestinian flag is going to be
raised outside the United Nations does
that now
yield to you like a hollow gesture given
just just how low the process how far
the process is now stalled now in the
contrary in 1947 Leo and decided to have
two states Israel and Palestine those
who say they support the two-state
solution they cannot just reverse one
state and refused to organize the other
state that's a deficiency so raising the
Palestinian flag tomorrow is a
reflection of the determination of the
Palestinian people to pee to be and to
revive their independence and the day
will come when we raise our flag and our
capital is Jerusalem now just finally
and briefly if you could I mean there
have been fears ever since the talks
broke down last year that there might be
some sort of uprising that the
frustration in the population is going
to spill over do you have that fear at
the moment well if is Rayleigh
settlement activities continue if there
is Rayleigh is aggression against
elastomers continue I hold the Israeli
government fully responsible for the
consequences of this I mean desperation
would be too desperate acts and we need
to stop this we need to stop the
desperation by having desirae government
comply with a for secession settlement
activities I'm not to accept to resume
negotiations to Delaney of the maps of
two states on the 19 67 lines dr. Erica
we're gonna have to leave it there thank
you very much for speaking to us like a
very much